s'il plus on vous rembourse
voilà la promesse que vous fait un
voyage à rêver mais sur le site internet
de lagence on découvre ce que la pub
petit pas d'abord pour avoir droit à un
remboursement
il faut qu'il pleuve cinq heures
consécutives huit heures 18 heures
durant au moins trois jours
nous avons consulté des météorologues
selon hu il est plutôt rare qu'il pleuve
cinq heures consécutives avant 18 heures
dans un pays tropical cela puisse se
produire lors de l'ouragan
mais la garantie ne couvre pas d'y jouer
et même s'il veut suffisamment voyages à
rabais ne vous remboursera elle vous
offre plutôt un crédit voyage valable
seulement un an selon deux avocats que
nous avons consultés il pourrait s'agir
de publicité trompeuse et sachez que
voyages à rabais peut modifier ou
annuler sa garantie à tout moment sans
se justifier
bref elle garantie soleil y a des
allures de pétard mouillé